العربيه ليست شاشه فقط بل شبكه من المنصات
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي تغطي كافه
اهتماماتكم بالخبر لذلك كان حضور العربيه
القوي على مختلف منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بمحتوى ينقل الشاشه الى هواتفكم وينجز لكم
مواد خاصه اخرى لاهتمامات قد تغيب عن
الشاشه احيانا
[موسيقى]
الاخر
ومعنا اليوم العناصر الفعليه التي تعمل في
هذا المحتوى وتحقق نتائج نفخر بها جميعا
معنا في الاستوديو الزميل محمد الحكواتي
مدير العمليات التقنيه في قناه العربيه
مرحبا بك محمد في هذه التغطيه وكل عام
وانت بخير ايضا ينضم الينا من الاستوديو
ايضا الزميل لويس بشاره منتج محتوى منصه
اكثر ويومنا جديده للعربيه تتميز ايضا
شكرا لك لوجودك معنا ومن رام الله ايضا
الزميل امجد سمحان مدير قسم التواصل
الاجتماعي في قناه العربيه مرحبا بك امجد
وانت دايما بعد قريب اليوم تبدو بعض
المسافات البعيده قليلا ولكن طاقه قريبا
دائما امجد محمد هناك دائما تساؤلات حول
التواصل الاجتماعي وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والى اي مدى يمكن ان تحل بالفعل
محل الشاشات نحن في العربيه حريصون كل
الحرص على ان يكون لنا تواجد قوي على هذه
المنصات بشكل مختلف كيف هي الارقام صحيح
هلا نحن العربيه طبعا غير القناه موجود
عنا الموقع الموقع متوفر باربع لغات
طبعا على الموقع عنا القراءات بشكل شهري
بتتراوح بين 20 مليون زائر وعدد القراءات
تتجاوز 60 مليون بشكل شهري بالنسبه لارقام
السوشيال ميديا امجد ممكن يفيدنا اكثر
بالارقام على المنصات السوشيال ميديا ماذا
عن السوشيال ميديا امجد وارقام متابعات
العربيه انت دائما ما تاخذنا في جلسات
واجتماعات وتعرض علينا الارقام كيف تبدو
الارقام امجد
حقيقه رشا بدايه كل عام وانتم بخير كل عام
وجميع الزملاء في العربيه بخير في هذا
الاحتفال يعني 20 عام من التميز ختمتها
العربيه في هذه السنه بصراحه ارقام
ملياريه على كافه المنصات نحن اليوم نتحدث
عن اكثر من مليار مشاهده على منصات
العربيه المختلفه
نتحدث عن اكثر من 220 حساب في هذه اللحظه
وفي كل لحظه عم يفتح عنا حسابات جديده نحن
لا نقول فقط ان العربيه هي الشاشه التي
يشاهدها المتابع وانما هي عباره عن شبكه
كبيره وضخمه من المنصات المختلفه التي
تقدم المحتوى باشكاله المختلفه سواء كان
المحتوى القادم من شاشه العربيه او
المحتوى المنتج خصيصا من خلال فرق
السوشيال ميديا
او حتى المحتوى الذي يخاطب الدول العربيه
بصفحات مخصصه لهذه الدول ارقام العربيه
كبيره جدا وهي في ازدياد وقوه العربيه
تاتي دائما من خلال هذه الارقام التي تعكس
صراحه مدى ثقه الجمهور بالعربيه ومدى
اهتمامه بالمحتوى الذي يقدم على منصات
العربيه واللي هو بيعكس سياسه العربيه
المهنيه والحرفيه والى اخره عندما نتحدث
رشا عن ارقام منصات التواصل المختلفه على
سبيل المثال دعينا ننتقل مثلا لاخر تغطيه
تغطيه زلزال تركيا سوريا خلال هذه الفتره
العربيه حققت مليار و600 مليون مشاهده
وهذا الرقم قياسي جدا يعني تتحدثين عن
مليار و600 مليون مشاهده على ما نشهر من
محتوى على مختلف منصاتنا عندما نتحدث عن
220 حساب للعربيه نتحدث عن كميه هائله من
الحسابات التي تضخ باستمرار مثلا
نحن ننشر سنويا اكثر من مليون ونصف
المليون منشور ايضا هذا الرقم كثير ضخم
وبالتالي كل ما يقدم من محتوى على منصات
التواصل هو في الاساس وما ياتي من خلاله
من ارقام هو في الاساس يعكس الرساله التي
انشات من اجلها العربيه وهي ايصال
المعلومه وايصال الخبر وايصال الحقيقه
ونقل المعرفه للجمهور العربي اينما تواصل
عندما نتحدث عن المحتوى مثلا نتحدث عن
اشكال مختلفه من المحتوى هناك المحتوى
الذي ياتي من الشاشه كانت استراتيجيه
العربيه ان تقوم بنقل الشاشه مباشره الى
هاتف المتابع اين موجود فصرنا نقوم
باقتطاع كليبات صغيره من ما ينشر او مما
يبث على منصاتنا سواء على نشرات الاخبار
او البرامج وكل ما ينتج على الشاشه من
محتوى ونقوم باقتطاع كليبات صغيره حتى
نستطيع نوصل للمشاهد العربي المعلومه في
الوقت القياسي والسريع وبالوقت المختصر في
الوقت ذاته الشاشه دائما تزدحم بالاخبار
والملفات واحيانا هناك بعض المواضيع التي
لا يمكن للشاشه ان تغطيها لهذا السبب او
لذاك
لذلك قمنا بانشاء منتجات او محتوى مخصص
فقط السوشيال ميديا يعني ما بنشوفه على
الشاشه هذا المحتوى يلبي رغبات الجمهور
الواسع والمتنوع والموجود يعني بفئات
عمريه
ايضا في بعض الاماكن رشا الدول عفوا الدول
العربيه على سبيل المثال مثلا في مصر او
في الجزائر او في تونس او في فلسطين هناك
صفحات للعربيه والحدث نتحدث عن الشبكه
تتناول الاخبار المحليه لهذه الدول واللي
ايضا الشاشه ربما لا تستطيع ان تغطيها في
هذا الوقت اباك بسبب الانشغال والزحمه
الاخباريه الموجوده نعم تفضل سنعود الى
الارقام مره اخرى وساعطي لك نفس عميق لترد
على السؤال القادم دائما يعني باستخدام
النيران الصديقه او حتى باستخدام بعض
المنافسين يقولون من اين اتيتم بهذه
الارقام وما الذي يؤكد انها ارقام صحيحه
وتؤكد حقيقيه صوتي لك نفس عميق لترد على
هذا السؤال واعود مره اخرى الى محمد محمد
نحن نتحدث عن واقع مختلف بالنسبه للصحافه
في العالم باكمله كيف تتعامل العربيه نجمع
هذا التطور المتلاحق والشديد تعلم ان هناك
صحف عالميه عريقه لسنوات طويله تواجه الان
ازمه في المحتوى وفي امكانيه وجود توزيعات
لها ومتابعين وما الى ذلك يعني احنا هلا
بالنسبه للعربيه مثل ما تفضل امجد احنا
المحتوى مش فصل ننقل محتوى القناه بكون في
مواضيع مخصصه بناء على شو الاهتمامات يعني
توسع في مواضيع الرياضه متوسف ومواضيع
المحليه في المواضيع الاقتصاديه بالاضافه
الى هيك بيكون
بالاضافه للسياسيه
فهي مثل نحكي مثل
تكون القناه بتنعكس للتعمق اكثر ممكن وقت
القناه ما بيسمح انه التعمق داخل المواضيع
بوقت اطول فبيكون الموقع والسوشيال ميديا
هي بتعطي مساحه اكبر للمحررين غرفه
بالاسهاب اكثر في الموضوع وعرضه
بالنسبه على الموقع احنا بنحاول نركز على
اهم شغلتين انه تكون سهوله وصول الموقع
وسرعه تحميل الصفحه وهذه من الناحيه
التقنيه لا احد يعني يعاني منها سهله
للغايه
احنا بالفتره الماضي اشتغلنا من المواكب
التكنولوجي بحيث تكون العربيه سباق مقارن
بكل المواقع الاخباريه العالميه بحيث تكون
بسموها
سرعه تحميل الصفحه باسرع وقت بالاضافه
الزميل الاستاذ ممدوح المهيني المدير
عامله قناه العربيه والحدث في حوار قريب
للشرق الاوسط قال ان الارقام تؤكد ان
الجمهور يشاهد المحتوى الجاد وليس كما
يتوقع البعض انه يشاهد بعض المحتويات من
التافهه او الغير مهمه هناك استناد الى
ارقام اكبر مثال الحادث الزلزال في الفتره
شاهدنا خلال فتره الزلزال بالساعات الاولى
ارتفاع عدد القراءات اربع اضعاف المتوسط
اللي بيجي على الموقع واستمرت هاي الفتره
لحد اليوم يعني لما يكون في خبر سياسي
كبير او حذف سياسي كبير بنلاحظ انه في
ارتفاع مهول بعدد القراءات على الموقع
تتجاوز ضعفين والثلاث اضعاف في لحظات
معينه ونفس الشيء بتلاقي لما يكون في
تغطيه مباشر للعربيه على القناه ارتفاع
ملحوظ على البث المباشر على الموقع لانه
العربيه هي مشاهده يعني تطلعوا على عشره
دول اللي عم تشاهد الموقع
حتلاقي السعوديه مصر الولايات المتحده
كندا المانيا الامارات الاردن لانه في
عالم مش سهل توصل للقناه عن طريق
التلفزيون التقليدي فبتلاقي بيحاولوا
يوصلوا للتغطيه العربيه عن طريق الوسائل
البديله من هالموقع منها السوشيال ميديا
فعشان هيك بنلاقي انه انتشار العربيه مش
محدود بس منطقه الشرق الاوسط لا منتشر على
على مختلف الدول العالميه
طيب
عود اعطيتك فاصل طويل امجد لتفكر في سؤال
جيدا فيما يتعلق بارقام المشاهدات البعض
يقول دائما
لم اكن بحاجه لهذا النفس لانه صراحه
الموضوع ليس اختراعا كل هذه الارقام
بامكان اي شخص ان يتابعها ويراها لانها
اصلا موجوده يعني هناك برامج موجوده لدى
صانعي المحتوى وغيرهم تتيح لاي شخص ان
يعمل البحث الذي يريد ليعرف ان كانت هذه
الامور حقيقيه او لا مثلا على سبيل المثال
هناك موقع وهو احد اهم المواقع التي ترصد
مشاهدات صانعي المحتوى على مستوى العالم
هذا الموقع بامكان اي شخص ان يشترك فيه
ويعرف ان كانت ما نقوله هو ارقام حقيقيه
او لا الحقيقه لا هي ارقام موجوده وهي
مثبته بعده بمئات الطرق وهي تعكس كما قلت
رشا مدى ثقه واحترام الجمهور
لما يقدم من محتوى عبر منصات العربيه نقطه
اخرى اريد ان اشير اليها اطلاقا ليس كما
كان الحوار مع زميلنا محمد المحتوى الذي
يحصل المشاهدات بشكل عام هو المحتوى
الرزين والمحتوى الهادف والمحتوى المتين
وليس كما يشاع او يقال هنا او هناك بانه
المحتوى الذي التافه بين قوسين يعني
اطلاقا مش صحيح
القوه العربيه بالتحديد تاتي من هذه
النقطه كل المشاهدات العاليه والارقام
القياسيه التي حققت على منصات العربيه
كانت في تغطيات التي
النقطه لانها مهمه للغايه تعلم ان احيانا
يتم اصدار بعض الاحكام ويقولون ان الجمهور
عايز كده والجمهور بريء يعني نحن نبارا
الجمهور الان من خلال هذه المشاهدات
هو
رشا الجمهور هو ذاته الجمهور الذي يشاهد
الشاشه هو الجمهور اللي موجود في المكان
ربما تختلف الاهتمامات من فئه عمريه الى
اخرى هذا لا يعكس او لا ينطبق اطلاق تماما
لا ينطبق على حاله هذه اطول مره اشاهد
فيها امجد يتحدث لن اكون اعرف انه
يتحدث
ان ينطم الينا ايضا الزميل لويس اب بشعرها
منتج محتوى منصه اكثر وهي ايضا منصه جديده
للعربيه مرحبا بك لويس لنعطي فكره
لمشاهدينا عن اكثر من اين اتت الفكره
ولماذا مساء الخير رشا مساء الخير بحب
عايدك وعايد كل مشاهدين قناه العربيه
بالعيد العشرين اكيد
اكثر ببساطه كتير بحب اني اشرح للناس
الفكره لانه هي جميله جدا
ولدت من الشعار الاحب على قلب كل الناس
ومتابعي قناه العربيه ان تعرف اكثر
فاخذناها الاكثر وديناها لمساحات اكبر عبر
السوشيال ميديا وصنعنا منا عده منصات
بتهم الناس بتهم الجيل الجديد بطريقه
شبابيه منصه بتحاكي جوانب الحياه المختلفه
من
من صحه التكنولوجي اشاهد بعض المحتوى الذي
تقدمه بشاره
وهو في بعض المعلومات الخاطئه الجمه
ورات الصحيه الخاطئه نحن في منصه اكثر
نصحح هذه المعلومات بشكل علمي صحيح هذا
نقطه كتير مهمه وهذه من التحديات اللي
يمكن اللي واجهت صناع المحتوى وخاصه اذا
كنا عم نمثل مؤسسه اعلاميه عريقه فلازم
نلتزم دائما بانه الاخبار تكون موثوقه في
ظل فيض من الاخبار ان كانت اخبار مغلوطه
او ان كانت حتى اخبار مش كامله فهون بيجي
دورنا كمنصه انه ننقل المعلومه الصحيحه
بكل المجال يتفاعل الجمهور معنا في هذه
المنصه الجديده اكثر يعني التفاعل نحن
بلشنا بشهر نوفمبر من السنه الماضيه 2022
التفاعل كان جميل جدا كبير جدا والناس
حقيقه عم بتحبوا عم بتشارك هذا المحتوى
طبعا التطلعات كتير كبيره والاهداف
المستقبليه عاليه جدا اكثر بدات بسبع
منصات ولكن نحن على طريق ماشيين لحتى
تتوسع هذه المنصات وتشمل جوانب اسمح لنا
انكمزعين دائما
لازم امجد يكون راضي عننا عشان المحتوى
بتاعنا يكون موجود امجد ماذا عن العلاقه
مع المنافسين امجد لاننا في النهايه نعيش
في عالم فيه تنافس شديد ليس فقط القنوات
تنافس بعضها ولكن ايضا السوشيال ميديا
تنافسنا في ما نقدمه من محتوى منافسه شرسه
وصعبه
لا شك رشا هناك عشرات المنافسين الذين
يقدمون محتوى لكن وهذا الشيء صراحه دائما
يدعونا الى المفخره العربيه يوجد بينها
وبين اقرب منافس مسافات صراحه خصوصا خلال
السنوات الثلاث الماضيه لانه استراتيجيه
العربيه قامت على انه احنا نوسع الانتشار
ونقوي المحتوى الموجود على منصات التواصل
يعني مثلا في عام 2022 حسب هذا الموقع
الذي اشرت اليه لابس العربيه كانت اكثر
صانع محتوى اخباري على مستوى العالم يحظى
بعدد مشاهدات سنويه احنا كنا نتحدث حينها
عن 14 مليار مشاهده حققتها منصات التواصل
في اكثر من مره تم تصنيف مواقع العربيه
على انها الاكثر متابعه ولاكثر مشاهده على
سبيل المثال العربيه كانت اول محطه توصل
عشره ملايين متابع على منصه يوتيوب حاليا
هي بين صانعي الاخبار هي الاولى من حيث
عدد المتابعين نتحدث عن 12 مليون متابع
على فيسبوك كذلك الحال العربيه لديها اكثر
من 30 مليون متابع ايضا على تيك توك
وبالمناسبه المنصه حديثه على صانعي
المحتوى العربيه هي الاولى الان لدينا
حوالي
مليونير متابع ولدينا مشاهدات مليونيه
العربيه منتشره بك والحدث طبعا الشبكه
كلها منتشره بكثافه من خلال المنصات
العديده ومن خلال المحتوى المتنوع والشامل
والاخباري الذي يقدم الى الجمهور وبالتالي
هذا جعل العربيه
او ستكون فكره جيده انه بالارقام
وبالارقام الموثوقه التي تحمل مصداقيه
وليس فقط كما يقال دائما بعض القنوات ليس
ان نتحدث عن قنوات بعينيها ولكن البعض
يقول نحن الاكثر نحن الاعلى نحن طيب فيما
يتعلق حكواتي رشا الارقام موجوده يعني انت
اليوم رشا فيك تروحي مثلا على المنافسين
منافسا منافسا وتشوفي مثلا عدد المتابعين
كم متابعين العربيه كم متابع للاخرين
فبالتالي بالنسبه لليوم لانك
تتحدث احنا نتحدث عن العربيه 20 سنه يا
رشا طبعا كل عام وانت بخير وكل زملاء
والاعزاء بخير وبسلام محمد هناك تساؤلات
حول ايضا كيف نتحدث مع الاخر اللغات التي
يتم الاعتماد عليها تمام هلا العربيه
انطلق الموقع بال 2004 ب
وجدت الحاج لاطلاق الموقع بلغه باللغه
الانجليزيه للوصول الناطقين باللغه
الانجليزيه والمهتمين باخبار المنطقه وعم
بيبحثوا عن مصدر للاخبار من قلب المنطقه
بالالفين وتسعه توسعنا كمان بالموقع
الفارسي والموقع الاوردو تمام غير توسع
اللغات احنا عم نتوسع على مختلف المنصات
غير منصات السوشيال ميديا العربيه مش بس
هي موقع موجود العربيه كتطبيق على الهواتف
الذكيه من اندرويد من ايفون موجوده على
السمارت واتشز موجوده على
السمارت بيز على الابل تي في
وحتى على الاجهزه
وموجوده على الاجهزه المنزليه مثل اليكسا
اللي فيك بس بامر صوتي تحكي اليكسا شو
اخبار اليوم بتلاقي العربيه بتحكي لها
ملخص اخبار اليوم واخر شيء
اطلقناه كان هو تطبيق العربيه على كار
بلاي بحيث انه تكون اذا حدا سيارته مهيئه
للكار او متوفر بتدعم الكار بلاي بمجرد
انت شبكه التليفون على السياره بتقدر
تستمع موقعنا بالانجليزيه هذا الموقع له
اهميه كبيره وتساؤل كبير بالنسبه
للمشاهدين والمتابعين من الخارج صحيح هلا
بالنسبه لانتشار موقع اللغه الانجليزيه
طبعا
من ناحيه القراءات
بالنسبه للمغتربين الموجودين في منطقه
الخليج في السعوديه في الامارات الغير
ناطقين باللغه العربيه طبعا احنا بنوجه كل
الاخبار بتكون موجهه لهم بالاضافه الى هيك
في
المتلقي الغربي
بالولايات المتحده في اوروبا وبالاضافه
الى هيك في الناطقين منلاحظ قراءات كثيره
من شرق اسيا ومن باكستان مع كل ذلك زميل
محمد الحكواتي مدير العاملات التقنيه في
قناه العربيه شكرا لك يا محمد وكل عام
وانت بخير والشكر لزملاء جميعا في القسمه
ايضا الشكر لزميلي لويس بشاره منتج محتوى
منصات اكثر شكرا لك وشكرا ايضا لزميلنا
امجد سمحان مدير قسم مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في قناه العربيه شكرا لك